- [Narrator] General
Tso's Chicken is a staple
in American Chinese restaurants.
But the most popular
Chinese dish in the U.S.,
is virtually unknown in China.
- [Narrator] So, what happened?
- [Narrator] It all started
after the Chinese Civil War
when most of the Chinese
leadership fled to Taiwan.
The leadership took this guy with them.
The late Peng Chang-Kuei.
He was after all the chef to the
then acting Chinese President.
On one fateful day there were a bunch
of foreign dignitaries in town.
- [Narrator] He named it
that because of General Tso,
a 19th century hero in
his hometown of Hunan.
- [Narrator] The dish was
a major hit in Taiwan,
so he brought it to the United States
and opened up a restaurant.
Word got out about Peng's restaurant
mainly because the then Secretary of State
Henry Kissinger was absolutely
bonkers for General Tso's.
- [Narrator] As with
most successful things,
people started ripping off the dish.
- [Narrator] Even though
the General Tso's chicken
you know and love probably
isn't the real McCoy,
don't let that stop you from gobbling up
that sweet and spicy,
gooey and crunchy mass.